- Are you eating a burger or
are you eating a sandwich?
The chopped cheese is like, I don't know.
- WTF chopped cheese?
Can you put it in a sentence for me?
(upbeat music)
- First glance kind of thing,
I'm assuming it's just like a
selection of chopped cheeses,
but that sounds like way too easy, right?
- I'm guessing it's a sandwich
since we're always
talking about delis now.
- I'm from Texas, we don't have that.
When someone said, "Are
you going to the Bodega?"
I said, "Who is she? I
don't know who she is."
(upbeat music)
- Sweet.
- There's ketchup on it.
- I'm not a ketchup person.
- Neither am I.
- I love me a good pressed sandwich.
Because when I was little,
I used to press my
sandwiches together anyway,
so I love that they did that for me.
- Man, I'm excited to know
what this is gonna taste like.
- Cheers.
- Mhhh!
- MM!
- This is banging!
- It's as if you grilled onions,
sweet onions in there chopped
up with the ground beef.
Homestyle Bubba Burgers.
- The mayonaise and tomato
add a little tang to it,
which is really good.
- This is like a circus in this piece.
- Oh (bleep) wait, is that ketchup?
- This would go so well with fries.
- Very minimal mess.
- If you like philly cheesesteaks,
and you like cheeseburgers,
you will like chopped cheese.
- Why do I do this to myself?
Why did I wait so long?
- I would give it a hard seven out of six.
- It's $4? Catch me getting three of this,
for breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
- Mmm.
- I would 100% buy this
on my next bodegaventure.
- If I ever am in Harlem,
this is probably like my first stop.
- Chopped cheese at Bodegas.
- At Bodegas.
- I love Bodegas.
- I enjoyed this even
though it had ketchup on it,
which I think is a really
glowing recommendation.
- I feel like I underestimated the power
that a bodega could pack
as far as food
and so I'm gonna give them a chance.
- Go New York!
- New York chopped cheese right here.
(bleep)ing love it.
I know everyone at Bodega.
I know the store cat manager.
(light music)